thanks for joining us around and this is
the Dave Ramsey show open phones a
triple eight eight two five five two two
five you can follow me on Twitter at
Dave Ramsey about 700,000 of you do
andrew says if there are two people both
serious about money and the first is
paying off a mortgage and the second is
renting and saving cash for a house
which is more wise well if we were going
to assume exactly the same sets of
income and exactly the same set of size
of house to purchase on the other thing
we'd have to assume to answer the
question correctly with math would be
that the rent was low very low and very
reasonable and it'll change the numbers
dramatically depending on the ratio of
house you're going to buy to the income
that you have an example would be let's
say you wanted to buy a one hundred
thousand dollar house and you made a
hundred thousand dollars and you were
newly married and you lived in a garage
apartment out back at some rich old
lady's house for 250 bucks and so you
saved fifty thousand dollars a year for
two years and you bought a house for a
hundred thousand dollars cash I think we
would call that very wise versus buying
a house at the immediately and paying it
off over two or three or in that case
five years maybe now here's why we would
call that wise the way I answer
questions is what would I do if I were
in your shoes so it's a little bit
twisted to jump into this scenario in
Drew it would be detaii it's we haven't
bought a house yet do we take out a
mortgage or do we rent cheap and save up
and pay cash that's an apples-to-apples
comparison you can't say someone's
already bought a house and then paying
that off versus saving up to pay cash is
not apples to apples because them
selling the house you know might or
might not be the right thing to do in
other words I very seldom tell somebody
to sell a house once they're in it and
as long as it's something they can
afford and instead
just crank their way through it and pay
it off but but if someone calls me and
says hey should I save up and pay cash
before I buy my house or should I buy
renting cheap and piling up a big pile
of cash or should I just buy now and
paid off as fast as I can and I would
tell you save up and pay cash for it I
would call that the wiser the way I know
that the way I decided that was again
what would Dave Ramsey do the way I make
my decisions on almost anything if I can
figure out what the Bible says about it
I do that and the Bible does not say
anything good ever about debt there's
not one time it's mentioned positively
in the Bible every time debts mentioned
you're a fool you're a slave it's a bad
idea it's a curse every time the debt is
brought up that's what it says now
that's God speaking as far as I'm
concerned because I'm a Christian and so
I believe that God is speaking there now
I don't believe that he's saying that
you're going to go to hell if you get a
MasterCard or a mortgage it's not a
Salvation issue as a matter of fact I'm
positive scripture does not say that I
also do not even think that it's a sin
some people say dead is a sin I don't
find that in the Bible I just think it
pretty much says you're stupid
so biblically speaking dead is stupid
it's not a sin not a Salvation issue now
the only reason I let my foot off the
gas on that it when someone's buying a
home here on the air it is to get a
mortgage you know a lot of people aren't
going to wait they're not going to do
the other stuff we talked about anyway
and so I I just try to slow them down
and keep them as as tight as I can and
then turning at the house paid off as
soon as possible I however personally
never borrow money for anything in any
circumstance you cannot make me afraid
or happy or greedy enough to borrow
money to go into a deal there's nothing
I want that bad ever I want to be
debt-free more than there's anything on
the planet I want and so I will never
trade that because it's
giving me that much freedom it's giving
me that much peace and I'm convinced
this one's reasons I've become wealthy
there's not any stinking payments and
you don't have any payments you know
what you have money all the money's not
going out the door then when all you do
is make money and pay payments you're
broke you've lost control of your most
powerful wealth building tool which is
your income and the borrower is slave to
the lender so to answer your question
enter if we were looking at to say young
couples as an example that don't own a
home and they're at the they're at the
starting line who's wiser who's going to
end up ahead at the finish line if
they're sitting there one's going to go
buy a house now and the others going to
rent very inexpensively and save up and
pay cash for a home very very quickly
not over 30 years but over three or four
or five years they're going to save up
cash and pay cash for their first home
and get started I'm going to tell you
that I think the debt-free couple is
going to when they cross the finish line
have more money and that's because I
believe in God and I believe he says
don't borrow money and he wouldn't say
that if borrowing money worked now that
sounds pretty basic but here's the deal
there's tons of math to back that up
and we can we can approach this
academically we can approach it
spiritually and I can show you and I can
walk you through a bazillion ways but
dude if you never I talked to a guy last
night I wasn't sure I went to a
Christmas party last night and I talked
to a guy last night that was worth
almost a billion dollars several hundred
million dollars and he comes up to me at
this party and starts telling me his
story because he knew you know what I do
on the radio and I had never met him
before and he starts telling me I've
never bought a dime in my life I've
never had a car payment I've never had a
house payment
I started from nothing my parents were
dirt farmers I had nothing and I took a
job as a teacher making five thousand
eight hundred dollars a year in 1962 or
whatever it was and I took that money
and I saved and I paid cash for our
first little house and I saved on paid
cash for a first
a piece of dirt and I built a house on
that with cash and I sold that house and
you know and then I did this and then I
did that and he just over the years has
built his wealth out of his cash flow
and it's grown exponentially and I meet
more of those than I do people who
leveraged their way into wealth borrowed
their way into wealth there's very few
of those occasionally I run into one but
almost none so that's it that's what it
comes down to the borrower is slave to
the lender and so I'm going to tell you
if I can talk you into paying cash for
everything I'm going to try now Wells
Fargo is running an ad right now that
everybody's tweeting me with us you know
this goober on there saying don't listen
to the debt boogie man the debt is not a
boogie man and of course that's aimed at
me because I'm telling people deaths
stupid never borrow money never do owe
money and I also tell people never to go
do business with mega banks like Wells
Fargo I mean why would you do business
with a bank like Wells Fargo or Bank of
America or Chase I mean you're a number
they don't care about you they really
don't and truthfully most of the best
bankers in the business and I'm not
against bankers why would you do
business with a mega bank they're
horrible customer service is horrendous
it's you know and then they run ads like
that you know it's like Discover card
was a discover cards got the Freedom
Card that's so stupid
that's like government service a freedom
credit card that's an oxymoron DMV
service line if the DMV had a line that
said Fastlane for you to get your get
your paperwork done fast you know we all
know what that would mean it would be a
lie and so we know that's not going to
happen
so think think think
you know oh yeah of course a banks is
gonna tell you borrowing money's a good
idea it's where they make all their
money is on bar on debt that's how they
make everything of course that's what
they're going to say think people why
would you do business with Wells Fargo
anyway just don't this is the Dave
Ramsey show you guys would be so rich so
fast and be able to do so much not only
for yourselves and for your family but
for others
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]